sentire un reggiano
iniziare con un proverbio africano
insomma mi fa pensare chiedo crea
anch'io probabilmente anzi tempo
praticamente partire con un proverbio
africano
si dice che
quando gli elefanti si combattono
classicamente chi ne fa le spese e
l'erba questo è un proverbio che dice
molto vuoi dire praticamente quando i
potenti si fanno la guerra a chi ne
soffre praticamente e la gente povera
sono i paesi praticamente poveri e molto
spesso anche i più ricchi di materie
prime come andremo a vedere
ed è questa constatazione che quattro
anni fa
ritornando nel mio paese di origine
il congo repubblica democratica del
congo
mi ha portato quando sono tornato in
italia a pensare a qualcosa perché
quello che ho trovato nel congo è un
assit è semplicemente l'inferno viene
definito proprio così l'inferno sulla
terra e la repubblica democratica del
paese ricchissimo ma oggi è l'inferno
sulla terra è quindi tornato in italia
ho pensato che cosa potessi fare per
fare conoscere un po questa situazione
da qui nasce questa idea questo progetto
di solidarietà di collaborazione ma
anche di convivenza perché soltanto
conoscendoci meglio riusciamo a vivere
insieme riusciamo a dire modo un modo
sostenibile ma anche
perché reggio emilia a reggio devo dire
che a reggio emilia dove vivo da 15 anni
un po queste cose come ha spiegato chi
mi ha preceduto
si vive un rapporto bello tra chi arriva
e chi riceve lo straniero si spera che
comunque questa idea anche sia portata
veramente in tutta l'italia di tutta
europa allora l'idea di marciare usare
il mio corpo praticamente perché l'unica
cosa che ho che nessuno mi può prendere
il mio corpo
ho deciso perché praticamente io ho
lasciato il paese 20 anni prima per
motivi politici e quindi ritornarci non
trovare più un amico aver perso il papa
il papa durante la guerra aver perso una
sorella dispersa
tornare qui
e pensare che cosa fare quindi pensato i
miei piedi il mio corpo questo nessuno
me lo può togliere e quindi ho pensato
di marciare partire da reggio emilia e
andare verso l'europa
però prima sono partito da solo come
andiamo a vedere e dopo la marcia da
reggio emilia roma c'era già tutta la
città di reggio emilia
molta gente ha seguito poi la marcia
dell'anno scorso reggio emilia bruxelles
sono cittadino congolese ma italiano da
due mesi esattamente ho firmato a due
mesi fa quindi è una cosa molto
importante poterlo dire da due mesi
e quindi chi meglio di me può parlare un
po di questa
situazione di convivenza a reggio è una
città dove si dove c'è convivenza e ho
visto anche in europa dove vedere a
maastricht è una situazione molto bella
e voglio sperare di amare molto l'italia
come amo reggio emilia so se avete
capito un po sono i tagli italiano però
amo molto reggio emilia e voglio spero
di poter amare anche l'italia ma il mio
cuore come c'è scritto il mio cuore
batte veramente congo repubblica
democratica del fondo
allora è più che un paese grandissimo
otto volte l'italia quattro volte la
francia 80 volte il belgio che ci ha
colonizzati un paese molto ma molto
ricco
situato nel centro dell'africa
dove però purtroppo da meno da poco meno
di vent'anni c'è una guerra economica la
guerra economica basata su
voglio chiedere una cosa c'è qualcuno
tra di voi che non ha un telefonino per
caso voglio vedere proprio qualcuno che
alza la mano c'è qualcuna che non ha un
telefonino
basta mettere le mani in tasca il congo
praticamente è un paese dove
c'è una guerra
da circa vent'anni che ha fatto 8
milioni di morti
ed è un problema di cui non parla
nessuno
una situazione di cui praticamente
nessuno ma proprio nessuno parla
l'ora
l'idea è
di questo è il congo praticamente
l'idea quindi è
andare
attraverso
l'europa
mi vergogno a far vedere questa cartina
qua dove si fa vedere praticamente tutte
le ricchezze queste sono le ricchezze le
ricchezze
praticamente
e tu paura che domani qualcuno di
politica io adesso fatto nel congo
perché lì si raccoglie praticamente le
cose
se un materiale molto importante che il
coltan
il coltan e quello che viene usato per
fabbricare i microchip i condensatori e
quello che ci permette oggi noi
di poter aver i telefonini che hanno
un'autonomia molto
elevata
qualcuno mi può dire il telefono non ce
l'ho e tiro va bene non c'è il telefono
ma scusate i bambini a casa non giocano
con un playstation
nel 96 mancava la playstation e in
italia perché c'era la guerra nel congo
in macchina il gps oppure year back
praticamente tutti noi abbiamo a che
fare con questo ma è a questa materia
prima fa
qualcuno mi dice ma cosa c'entro io con
il conto che a 6.000 chilometri da el
italia
cosa c'entro io
io voglio dire che il congo si è molto
lontano ma molto lontano la metto molto
lontano ma se noi ci svegliamo la
mattina
già rispondere a una chiamata
significa che sto consumando quando è
questa materia prima come di utente vi
farò vedere velocemente questa materia
prima praticamente col tale viene
chiamata addirittura oggi coltan
insanguinato perché ci abbiamo le mani
insanguinate
perché porta morte
quindi
è una sorta di sabbia nera
che 30 anni fa lui calpestava mo e non
sapendo che cosa fosse proprio e costa 2
centesimi al chilo nel congo in europa
costa
500 euro
500 euro al chilo per capire ed è in un
circuito di sfruttamento illegale che è
praticamente finanzia questa guerra che
in poco meno di vent'anni ha fatto 8
milioni di morti certificati almeno 6
milioni dall'onu
silenzio totale da parte della comunità
internazionale a cosiddetta comunità
internazionale i media
ecco perché io ho deciso di marciare
fintanto che non si comincia a parlare
di questa situazione
io sono in lutto siamo in lutto
praticamente è da un anno che
si può render esteriore fare vedere
perché questo è il sangue di 8 milioni e
il lutto del congo dei congolesi
senza commento
capite quindi l'informatica
l'industria aerospaziale
il telefonini come detto lightech chi ha
chiamato il loro loro dell'informatica
lo ha detto che il convegno né di tutto
conseguenza i bambini che fanno i
minatori e il coltan e radioattivo
nessuno dice a questi bambini che il
coltan radioattivo
i bambini soldati ne avete senso parlare
quindi c'è una responsabilità oggettiva
dell'occidente di tutti noi non è
un'accusa questa qua è un'amara
veramente un'amara constatazione tutti
noi me compreso che vivo qua che sono
davanti a voi
in quanto uso il telefonino tutto quello
che abbiamo abbiamo a che fare con
questo problema quindi non possiamo più
rimanere in silenzio
e quindi
da questo bisogna fare io ho pensato
teso a sensibilizzare perché io non
posso venire davanti a voi e dire che ci
abbiamo le mani insanguinate che noi
condividiamo questa responsabilità se
voi non avete la possibilità di sta per
una rete ha avuto la consistenza terra
ecco perché ecco perché sono andato in
giro e in spagna in italia
in europa per raccontare un po questa
situazione e sembra che la gente stia
veramente rispondendo positivamente
perché ci sono convegni preparati fra
poco a maastricht bruxelles e quindi c'è
gente che segue che vuole sapere di più
quindi il punto principale di questa
cosa che porta e bisogna arrivare a una
legge sulla tracciabilità del contante
diciamo che questa è la cosa principale
tracciabilità del poeta leiva o tu vai a
comprare un telefonino un regalo per un
amico ai la scelta perché c'è un
certificato che dice il coltan che c'è
in questo telefono io due giorni fa per
tanto per entrare in questa ottica di
questa spiegazione sono andato a
chiedere un telefonino in un negozio due
negozi
ho chiesto al al commesso il coltan da
dove arriva mi ha chiesto cosa così che
cosa questo coltan se io so che il
coltan perché è certificato che il
coltan proviene dal fondo ma è tutto
spiegato quindi non e incolta hanno
insanguinato allora io compro quella di
magari pagando un po di più
e l'unico modo perché oggi è difficile a
parlare di boicottaggio perché bisogna
arrivare un boicottaggio di certi
prodotti però non avendo scelta
alternative è impossibile quindi l'unica
cosa che stiamo portando anche alle
istanze internazionali è praticamente
una legge internazionale sulla caccia
vita del poeta quindi anche delle
sanzioni a chi non presenta un
certificato
soltanto allora io potrei venire da voi
e dire perché continuato a usare un
telefono
il cui coltan e non sapete neanche da
dove arriva perchè continuate a uccidere
milioni e milioni di persone soltanto ad
allora
quindi adesso perché si sta facendo
e sensibilizzare parlare portare questa
idea affinché veramente la comunità
internazionale
arrivi a una legge come hanno provato a
fare poi nel tt di amanti si arrivi
veramente non c'è nessuno che può dire
che non ha a che fare con questi morti
e quindi la creazione di una rete di
sensibilizzazione qualcosa che sta
partendo visistato tante scuole in
italia un po meno a reggio emilia
diciamo ma tante scuole tante scuole a
bruxelles maastricht un po in giro per
l'europa e quindi la prima marcia come
ho detto insomma 900 km insomma in
spagna francia spagna poi 700 un po una
passeggiata da reggio emilia sino a
bruxelles proprio una passeggiata
e qui c'era già il sostegno morale della
città
poi 1600 anche di più perché c'è un
persi tante volte qui c'è anche un amico
giordano è un reggiano
così come sono reggiano un reggiano che
ho conosciuto
il giorno prima della marcia ed è venuto
con messina bruxelles però hanno
partecipato a questa marcia e nove
nazionalità
noi abbiamo girato praticamente sette
paesi europei
risultati pochi però diciamo che ci sono
stati qualche qualche decisione da parte
dell'unione europea e adesso ci sono
anche incontri prossimi sembra al
parlamento
però la cosa importante sono i cittadini
sono le persone sono le scuole sono i
giovani che domani saranno chiamati a
decidere
se lo sanno oggi domani potranno
prendere delle decisioni giuste
siamo interdipendenti se capiamo questo
io c'ho il coltan tuoi servizio capiamo
questo io vivo bene qua
viviamo bene con i congolesi con
l'africa
e possiamo tutti insieme veramente penso
fermare la guerra
penso lo spero e attenzione qui
noi potremmo veramente dire
questa immagine che presenta il telefono
insanguinato le mani e sanguinati il
coltan vogliamo continuare ad avere gli
occhi bendati e fare finta
io spero proprio di no spero di non
potere veramente più vedere un'immagine
di questo tipo qua
faccio vedere velocemente questa è la
partenza della marcia da reggio emilia
quindi vedete c'è stata una risposta da
parte della città
a vedere un po di persone quasi 50 60
persone un incontro con i ragazzi
un incontro istituzionale
c'erano anche loro siamo stati dai no
tav perché non sembra giusto
momenti molto difficile anche perché non
era proprio una camminata di piacere un
momento dove insieme al teatro mi sembra
ginevra
l'argentina in francia però è di certo
un po scherzando forse la prossima meta
però diciamo che sono così un incontro
al parlamento a strasburgo la mente
europeo i ragazzi la città di maastricht
ha mandato 30 ragazzi a circa 15 16
chilometri che hanno fatto con noi la
fine della mazza è questo qua è un trio
praticamente io giordano e simon cioè
abbiamo fatto tutto il percorso da
reggio fino a fino a bruxelles però ci
sono state anche tantissime altre
persone ma tante persone nove
nazionalità
amo come detto reggio emilia spero di
amare molto l'italia ma amo molto la
repubblica democratica del congo
faccio vedere velocemente un contributo
della marcia
stavano arrestando
les combes
vi ringrazio